the debate over briar's successor is
going to give this president and his
party a rallying cry at a moment that
they badly need something to rally
around he can now say
i am going to fight the good fight and i
am going to get this nominee this could
be a real jolt i think to rank and file
voters
the mainstream media celebrating the
news that supreme court justice stephen
breyer is set to retire joe koncha joins
us now joe i understand that this is a
good distraction theory i just don't
know if i agree with that theory are the
american voters focused on the court
selection process or are they focused on
the fact that they are having trouble
putting food on the table filling up
their gas pump and oh by the way crime
everywhere
i'm going to take b c and d in that
multiple choice todd uh i don't i'm with
you on this one and carly was right to
describe it as celebrating because i
haven't seen him this giddy in quite
some time we're talking about many in
media i just don't see this development
regarding briar's retirement as any kind
of real game changer if a conservative
on the bench like clarence thomas had
announced his or her his retirement uh
then
that justice being replaced by a liberal
that's a different ball game but the
court remains 6-3 or 5-4 conservative
here and since biden already said he
would name a black woman to the bench
there's no wow factor because he's
simply shooting par look the supreme
court is important i get that but when
simply bringing in a lefty relief
pitcher from the same team to hold the
score where it is it's not the big story
many and media are making it out to be
when compared to as you listed inflation
crime education the border and all that
arrested overseas with russia and
ukraine
there is a tweet from a senior staffer
at the democratic congressional campaign
committee that we would like to
highlight this person said another
another devastating threat on how police
and for hire pr propagandists are
coordinating with journalists to falsely
manufacture crime waves and create
narrative spin the media regularly
publishes propaganda disguised as
reporting that misleadingly relies on
police and their proxies so in layman's
terms he's saying that the police are
working with reporters to inflate how
many crimes are happening across the
country despite the numbers that we're
actually getting that show that crimes
are spiking across the country joe
wow looks like the dcc is see there's a
lot of season that is getting
their cues from another acronym cnn or
at least their media team which over the
weekend tried to spend 25 year high in
murders in this country that's according
to the fbi it's a problem but it's
really just an exaggerated one nobody
believes this narrative that crime isn't
impacting many americans and cities and
suburbs across this country because they
watch the local news or they read local
publications or maybe they talk to their
neighbors it's real and instead of
offering solutions they're actually
trying to blame the media on this one
it's a bold strategy cotton and by the
way the party's gonna pay for this if
they don't start offering solutions
instead of just complaining about a
problem and saying it doesn't exist when
it actually does when that red tsunami
comes in november i wrote the dodgeball
reference in my question so i'm happy
that joe actually thank you use the
reference um you mentioned cnn our old
friend jim acosta from the cnn making
some bold comments about virginia
governor glenn young and take a listen
i seem to remember glenn younkin
campaigning in a fleece vest
in virginia he was running as a
different kind of republican i was told
there was going to be a vest
not a soviet-style police state across
the potomac from washington joe how can
someone demonstrate such a lack of
knowledge of history albeit
on cnn and albeit in front of veritable
tens of viewers
uh the answer being i like that tens of
viewers uh fnr friends and relatives
watching at this point uh it's because
jim acosta is the king of cheesy
hyperbole let's just crown the guy right
now this is the same guy who said he had
quote marks on his back from the trump
era i'm not joking that's an actual
quote this is the same guy who's guest
hosting the 9pm show for cnn this week
and somehow is generating the lowest
network for any show on that network
despite being in the best time slot
acostas show this week by the way is
called democracy in peril it should be
called sanity in peril because when you
start comparing the commonwealth of
virginia to a soviet state you've either
a never studied soviet history or b
you're seeking attention and no one begs
for attention quite like jim acosta the
heavyweight champ of cheesy hyperbole
guys
yeah and glenn juncken what he's trying
to do is give parents a choice when it
comes to masking in schools and critical
race theory i don't think that soviet
police are very are known for giving
people choices joe thank you it's what
people voted for thanks guys take care
hi everyone i'm brian kilmeade i want
you to do me a favor i want you to click
to subscribe to the fox news youtube
page this is the only way that i know
for sure that you're not going to miss
any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on fox you can get it all here on
youtube so subscribe right now